buonasera a tutti
[Applauso]
io nella vita sono sempre stato un
grande appassionato di videogiochi ho
avuto la fortuna di lavorare da entrambi
i lati della barricata sia dal lato di
chi videogiochi si produce e li
commercializza sia dal lato di chi li
studia di critica ne analizza quindi
quando mi è stato proposto di parlare
del tema delle origini devo dire che
sono stato colpito da un grande
entusiasmo perché sono fermamente
convinto che i videogame sia il mezzo di
comunicazione di massa che più di ogni
altro incarna il tema delle origini
perché ogni volta che noi premiamo il
tasto start
noi diamo origine a qualcosa di nuovo a
una nuova storia a una nuova avventura
la nostra partita che spesso sfocia in
nuovi ricordi quindi in qualche modo
l'origine è innata nel videogioco stesso
tuttavia ragionando su che cosa
raccontarvi questo pomeriggio e cercando
di capire in che modo direzionare il mio
discorso alla fine mi sono imbattuto in
un fatto cioè mi sono reso conto che nel
momento in cui io parlo di origine al
singolare
sto dicendo qualcosa di diverso rispetto
a quando io parlo di origini al plurale
ossia origine e origini solo due parole
diverse hanno proprio uno spostamento
semantico nel momento in cui io vado a
declinarla al plurale vi spiego perché
quando io parlo di origine
mi riferisco a un punto fermo nello
spazio tempo posso parlare di origine
dell'universo posso parlare di origine
della repubblica italiana posso parlare
della mia origine quando è la mia
origine e dove la mia origine foto per
gentile concessione di mamma arriva il
15 gennaio
1984 alle ore 11 e 0 1 del mattino
ammesso e concesso che l'orologio
dell'ostetrica fosse preciso dove
all'ospedale santa chiara di trento
quindi insomma io ho un punto nello
spazio nel tempo in cui perlomeno da un
punto di vista legale arrivo su questo
pianeta quindi l'origine la mia origine
riesco a trovarla ma nel momento in cui
io parlo delle mie origini
è evidente che non mi trovo sullo stesso
piano
tutto diventa un po più fumoso più
confuso meno quantificabile perché le
mie origini sono certamente nei miei
genitori
io sono frutto di una scelta da parte
dei miei genitori sono anche frutto di
una serie di tentativi non ho mai
chiesto a papà quanti però certamente ci
sono stati dei tentativi e le mie
origini sono anche dei miei nonni i miei
antenati donne e uomini che magari non
ho neanche mai conosciuto ma che hanno
trasmesso il loro corredo genetico hanno
trasmesso le loro conoscenze
a chi poi mi ha dato origine ma le mie
origini sono anche nella mia infanzia
nella mia formazione nei miei insegnanti
nei miei professori e perché no nella
mia lingua
nella mia cultura in quello che mangio
capite che non siamo sullo stesso piano
quindi nel momento in cui io devo
parlarvi di origine del videogioco è di
origini del videogioco di origini mi
viene abbastanza facile perché potendo
attingere da
uno stagno molto ampio
è evidente che posso stare più a
raccontarvi le origini del videogioco ma
se devo trovare un punto nello spazio
tempo che mi dice qui inizia il
videogioco diventa molto più complicato
quindi come faccio a risolvere questo
problema avendo io fra le mie origini
una formazione di tipo cinematografico
studiato storia del cinema posso
appoggiarmi alla metafora del cinema e
quindi raccontarvi come inizia la storia
del cinema in modo tale da trovare un
punto di appoggio per trovare l'origine
del videogioco quindi il cinema quando
nasce il cinema di nuovo punto fermo
nello spazio tempo il cinema nasce il 28
dicembre 1895
data estremamente precisa era sera
l'orario non lo conosco con esattezza
però vi posso anche dire il luogo il
luogo è parigi
e per la precisione il luogo è in una
strada di parigi chiamata bulvar dei
caps in in boulevard de capuccini c'è un
caffè chiamato gran caffè del caps in
sta nel nono rondismo e in questo caffè
se vogliamo essere ancora più precisi è
un salone chiamato salon cambia il
salone indiano e in questo salone quella
sera del 28 dicembre 1895 succede
qualcosa succede che un gruppo di
persone
arrivano in questo locale pagano un
biglietto entrano in una sala del tutto
simile a quella dove dove siete seduti
voi oggi
e attendono l'inizio di qualcosa uno
spettacolo a un certo punto
parte un forte ronzio
dall'ultima fila
un raggio di luce colpisce un lenzuolo
bianco
posto virtualmente alle mie spalle e
appare questa immagine
ora cercate di
visualizzare siamo nel 1895 la
fotografia esiste già da diversi decenni
le diapositive esistono già da parecchio
tempo il pubblico è abituato a vedere
una foto
quindi in qualche modo non c'era nulla
di nuovo in questo spettacolo
il problema è che questa foto si muove
vedete abbiamo un un binario un facchino
questo è evidentemente una stazione è
improvvisamente accade questa cosa qui
abbiamo un treno che si avvicina sempre
di più la gente comincia a guardarsi un
po perplessa e ad un tratto quando il
treno arriva in questo punto qui una
persona in prima fila si alza si volta e
urla questo treno c'è ammazzerà tutti
comincia a cercare disperatamente
l'uscita calpesta le persone nelle prime
file si fionda fuori e scatta il panico
tutti sono convinti che questo treno
stia entrando nella sala
d'altro canto due mesi prima era
successo un fatto a parigi un treno e la
stazione di montparnasse aveva superato
l'ultimo binario aveva sfondato la
paratia ed era caduto su una edicola
uccidendo il povero edicolante che si
trovava il suo interno è solo per un
miracolo non esplosa la caldaia della
locomotiva ammazzando tutti i passanti
quindi chiaramente immaginatevi tutti
avevano paura che si ripetesse questa
scena e tutti si sono riversati
nelle strade nella strada inglobarle
kapustin la gente era
preoccupatissima e si creò una piccola
folla di curiosi attorno attorno a
queste persone spaventate che ladri ma
che cosa è successo e uno disse
eravamo lì è entrato un treno
è che qualcuno disse ok io lo voglio
vedere questo treno che è entrato nel
caffè e quindi comincio a mettersi in
fila pronto a pagare un biglietto per
vedere per essere anche gli
terrorizzato e vedere questo treno che
entrava nella sala cinematografica
quel giorno nasce la leggenda del
cinematografo lumiere
ho detto leggenda perché quanto vi ho
raccontato in realtà non è mai accaduto
magari una storia che avete sentito
questa magari l'avete vista anche
parodizza ton e mi fece una parodia
anche paolo villaggio in superfantozzi
col treno che entrava in sala il
poverino investiva davvero fantozzi ma
questa cosa non è mai accaduta perché il
28 dicembre 1895 ci fu sì la prima
proiezione di un film dei fratelli
lumière
e il problema che in questa prima
proiezione il film che avete visto che
si chiama all'arrivo di un treno alassio
sat non fu mai proiettato fu proiettato
il 6 gennaio successivo
inoltre la gente sapeva esattamente che
cosa avrebbe visto quella sera perché
avevano pagato un biglietto in cui
sapevano che sarebbero andate a vedere
uno spettacolo di immagini in movimento
erano tutti rilassati tutti tranquilli
vedere lo spettacolo era bello
passaparola e nacque il cinema perché
dunque si fissa la nascita del cinema in
quella data
perché quel giorno la
gente entra in un locale paga un
biglietto si sedette in una sala e vide
un film che è la stessa cosa che tutti
noi facciamo da 127 anni quando diamo al
cinema quel giorno nasce lo spettacolo
cinematografico moderno si paga un
biglietto per andare in sala e vedere un
film ok quindi capite possiamo trovare
un punto zero in questa storia perché è
lì che nasce lo spettacolo
cinematografico moderno ora se ci
spostiamo sui videogiochi di nuovo
parlando di origini mi viene facile
perché le origini dei videogiochi si
ritrovano nelle scienze che hanno dato
vita ai videogame nella matematica nella
fisica
nell'informatica queste scienze però
portano con sé una un'emozione
tipicamente umana che è la noia
ora immaginatevi che cosa significa che
una persona che lavora ad esempio in un
centro in un in un luogo dove si fanno
delle ricerche come può essere il
brookhaven national laboratory che si
trova sulla sulla east coast degli stati
uniti quando si organizzano le visite
guidate ed entrano scolaresche e parenti
dei
dipendenti di questo centro di ricerca
e si ritrovano a vedere tutti quegli
strumenti scientifici utilizzati nel
laboratorio con questa guida turistica
che con la sua flemma dice ecco qui un
potenziometro da 75 home è chiaro che
dopo dieci minuti tutti erano morti per
terra dalla noia
quindi che cosa accade che uno di questi
scienziati che siano da william
higginbotham
pensa di poter risolvere questo problema
della noia introducendo uno strumento
scientifico che sia divertente da
utilizzare e si inventa questo coso qua
si chiama penny sforzi è un
oscilloscopio quindi uno strumento usato
realmente in laboratorio adattato per
simulare una partita di tennis
la guida turistica quella del dei
potenziometri da 75 home
a un certo punto si gira e non trova più
nessuno perché tutti saranno messi in
fila per giocare a questo primo esempio
di videogame però queste sono origini
sono esperimenti non ci fu una
commercializzazione di questo prodotto
di conseguenza se noi vogliamo usare la
metafora cinematografica a trovare il
punto zero della nostra storia dobbiamo
necessariamente
andare da un'altra parte
dobbiamo trovare il momento in cui il
videogioco diventa effettivamente
fruibile da tutti e questo momento
arriva all'inizio degli anni settanta
tra la fine del 71 e inizia il 72 quando
una coppia di studenti in realtà avevano
abbandonato gli studi
inventarono
anzi inventarono non è il termine
corretto presero in prestito un
videogame già realizzato precedentemente
e diffuso solo all'interno dei campus
universitari ed ebbero due intuizioni
geniali la prima quella di creare una
macchina un computer capace di
riprodurre solo quel gioco e quindi
rifiuti riducendo enormemente i costi di
produzione
il secondo luogo inserirono all'interno
di questa macchina una gettoniera c'è
uno strumento che inserito una moneta da
25 centesimi un quarto di dollaro
permetteva a un giocatore di giocare una
partita a questo gioco
poco dopo rielaborarono l'idea e fecero
un gioco originale questo gioco che è
diventato anche questo leggendario si
chiamava si chiama pong
l'uomo alla sinistra si chiama the dub
lì l'uomo la destra della macchina si
chiamano l'amburgo il terzo protagonista
è lei la nostra gettoniera e questo
gioco fu installato per la prima volta
di nuovo torniamo al paragone
cinematografico
fu installato all'interno di un locale
si chiamava handicap tavern era un pub
il gioco la prima macchina venne
lasciata lì da bush nel attesero di
vedere se qualcuno ci avrebbe realmente
giocato il giorno dopo il gestore del
locale chiama bushnell le dice nolan
viene riprenderti una macchina perché
non funziona al che bushnell dice
impossibile la mia macchina è progettata
correttamente qualcuno ci avrà versato
sopra della birra o magari un giocatore
frustrato l'avrà presa a calci e si è
rotta quindi parte va al locale con un
tecnico vede la macchina si accorge che
non c'è segno di birra negli altri
alcolici sul sulla macchina nessuno l'ha
presa a calci ma la macchina
effettivamente non funziona
quindi va dalla nostra amica gettoniera
apre lo sportellino per vedere che cosa
è successo e si accorge che sono state
inserite così tante monete che la
cassettina che le raccoglie si è
sfondata inondando i circuiti di quarti
di dollaro
in quel momento si accorsero che questa
idea qui aveva uno sviluppo commerciale
in quel momento il videogioco divenne
democratico perché con 25 centesimi
tutti potevano giocarci e non dovevano
essere iscritti a un campus
universitario essere ricercatori o
possedere un computer costava decine di
migliaia di dollari quindi è evidente
che se noi dobbiamo trovare un punto
zero in questa storia io lo troverai qui
dove il videogioco trova una sua
dimensione popolare è utilizzabile da
tutti
gli ho raccontato questa storia perché
durante
l'elaborazione di questo discorso mi
sono ritrovato in una sorta di
autoanalisi a riflettere su me stesso
cercare di capire quali sono le mie
origini cioè perché io oggi mi trovo qui
e vi racconto questo
e quindi mi sono domandato
qual è il momento il punto zero che mi
ha fatto decidere di intraprendere
questa questa avventura questa carriera
e ve lo racconterò molto brevemente
avevo 18 anni era l'estate di me 18 anni
io sono come avete visto del trentino
molti miei coetanei
alla mia età vanno in estate a
raccogliere mele o
ad occuparsi di turismo lavorando nei
locali per tirare su qualche soldo io
avendo una grande passione vado a
lavorare in un negozio di videogiochi
vado a fare il commesso di un negozio di
videogiochi
in questo negozio avevo questo capo che
era una persona
avete presente il mister craps di
spongebob chirchio che non bisognava mai
restituire i soldi ai clienti provi con
una signora crabs che teneva la loro
relazione per le redini per non
utilizzare altri appendici e lo
costringeva ad andare in vacanza quindi
un mi ritrovavo in agosto un mese a
gestire da solo un negozio era un
bambino in un
negozio di dolciumi con la differenza
che questo bambino era diabetico perché
i giochi non li potevo scartare e
giocare
però uno di questi giochi era già aperto
di questo gioco si chiamava vietcong era
come potete intuire un gioco di guerra
ambientato ai tempi del vietnam e giocai
all'ultima copia presente in negozio
giocai allo sfinimento questo titolo
ritenendolo un prodotto di altissima
qualità è un gioco che aveva molte cose
da raccontare
finché a un certo punto non si presenta
in negozio una persona un ragazzo sulla
trentina che mi chiese uno sparatutto
io giocando questo vietcong a malincuore
gli dissi questo è il gioco migliore che
puoi trovare quest'anno lui non era
tanto convinto io gli raccontai tutto
ciò che c'era di bello in questo gioco
ma lui insomma non non mi sembrava
propenso ad acquistarlo finché cala il
asso di bastone e gli disse senti se non
ti piace me lo riporti negozio
cielo ricompro io con i miei soldi
sapendo che mister craps in questione
non l'avrebbe mai restituito il denaro
quindi lui prese il gioco se ne andò io
me ne dimentica i e questo ragazzo non
lo vidi più
passano tre settimane mi trovo dalla
parte opposta del trentino proprio 40
chilometri di distanza da dove stare al
negozio e all'epoca avevo una
fidanzatina il padre aveva una casa di
campagna dove si organizzavano delle
grigliate io vado lì per fare questa
questa grigliata alla fine lui mi diceva
barry accompagna
la mia figlia a casa
avevo questo motorino un benelli tre
marce rumorosissimo un solo casco
all'epoca si poteva andare in motorino
soltanto con una persona quindi metto da
gentiluomo il casco alla ragazza saliamo
in due partiamo super questa strada
alzando un polverone mostruosa facendo
un rumore incredibile e penso tra me e
me
che cosa mai potrà accadere in una
strada polverosa di campagna in mezzo
alle montagne del trentino giro alla
curva
paletta carabinieri alt primo vertico
che è finita
vedo la mia vita passarmi davanti mio
padre che mi vuole ammazzare
e in quel momento è successo ciò che mi
ha fatto dire io farò questo nella vita
perché questo carabiniere si toglie gli
occhiali mi guarda e mi dice che ho
fermato solo per dirti il videogioco è
una figata e non ce lo riporto in
negozio grazie